let's bring in Ben Shapiro
editor-in-chief of The Daily wire host
of the Ben Shapiro show it says here the
largest and fastest growing conservative
podcast in the country we have not in
impartial e fact checked out but Ben
since you say it every day think we'll
take it at least as truth right now nice
to see you my friend
the president says now it all starts to
make sense is this FBI agent a critical
piece of a puzzle I'm not sure the FBI
agent is a critical piece of the puzzle
but it's pretty clear for a long time
that the FBI has its own biases and to
remove those biases would be to paint an
impartial not complete picture when one
of the problems here is that we know
that James Comey was basically letting
Hillary Clinton off with nothing but a
public slap on the wrist now we know
that another FBI agent who is working on
that particular case was biased against
President Trump one of the things I
haven't found out from the story maybe
you can tell me I just don't know is how
we knew that this agent was doing this
if we found it out from Mueller's
investigation then Mueller fired him
then that obviously reflects better on
Mueller than if this were an outside
force that had found out that this FBI
agent was biased against President Trump
and then Muller had to fire him for no
other reason
great question our reporting from James
Rosen and also Jake Gibson on this was
that Comey fired him I haven't heard
exactly how was that Muller fired him
exactly how that transpired as you point
out will be very interesting to figure
out the president saying that the FBI's
reputation is in tatters if everything
is political and nothing is sacrosanct
anymore does that become a larger
problem for the Republic well it's
certainly a problem when we have no
trust in any of our institutions I mean
the president is it worth the FBI the
FBI's or at the president the the
president's at war with parts of the DOJ
right now it seems like no one trusts
any member of any institution and that
means that you're just going to side
with the PERT of the people that you
feel best about the people who you agree
with most unpoliced
there's a poll out today from Alabama
showing that a vast majority of members
of the Alabama voting public feel that
Roy Moore is innocent not because they
actually have verified the fact but
because they don't trust the media that
demonstrates the level of antipathy
toward the media level of antipathy
which I don't think is completely
unwarranted so yes as the institutions
are torn apart it's going to be very
difficult to put the country back
together we're not operate
off the same basis of common facts
speaking of institutions you can also
include in those institutions American
tradition one tradition is that former
presidents do not speak ill of the
current president especially overseas
take listen to President Obama see if
you think he violated that now I grant
you that at the moment we have a
temporary absence of American leadership
on the issue Obama they're talking about
American leadership on climate change
but still what a break yeah I mean this
is kind of usual for Democratic
presidents actually Bill Clinton was
largely absent during the Bush
administration but Jimmy Carter
obviously never went away I mean he's
still running around blabbing about
whatever he feels like blabbing about
President Obama couldn't last a full
year before he started going abroad and
talking about the current presidents of
the United States George W Bush has been
absent from the public scene since he
left public office so you know there is
a pretty stark gap it seems to me
between Republican axe presidents and
democratic ex presidents when it comes
to speaking about that the people who
come right after them of the opposite
party Matt Drudge tweeting out what
about a logan act investigation of a
citizen obama conducting american
foreign policy it's a nice quip but it
makes an important point yeah I mean I
think that the fact is that you know a
lot of people are saying that Mike Flynn
violated the Logan Act when he was
talking with the Russian government
about policy for the incoming
administration the Logan Act is probably
unconstitutional it's really never been
enforced I think there's been one trial
on it since it was imposed in the in the
very very end of the the 18th century I
don't see you know why what Mike Flynn
was supposed to be doing talking the
Russian ambassador is so bad and the
fact that mattre I'm just pointing out
that if we're gonna start going Logan
act on people that Barack Obama would be
in that in that penalty box he's not
wrong about that I mean Nancy Pelosi if
you recall during the Bush
administration was flying over to Syria
and making her own foreign policy so if
we're gonna start doing the if we're
gonna start imposing the the Logan Act
has some sort of actual legal standard
there gonna be a lot of people who find
themselves in the dock well it's too bad
you won't have anything to talk about
tomorrow on your podcast all right
we'll see you then thanks as always good
to see you thanks so much
all right